Chris Evans has a new girlfriend but
only new to his fans you got that right
yeah actress Alba Baptista has been with
a Marvel star for more than a year I got
lucky it's all kind of
timed out well for me we're learning the
newest sexiest man alive kept our
romance on the down low what went
through my mind my mom will be so happy
and his moms probably met the lucky lady
in her son's life by now our source says
quote they are very in love and their
relationship is serious Chris has never
been happier his family and friends all
adore Alba looks like we're gonna have
to make history so who's Alba well she's
one of Portugal's biggest stars and like
her new boo
foreign
the 25 year old seen plenty of action
starring in Warrior none
and it's not the first time Chris has
dated within Hollywood so many Ninja
machines are always a little awkward you
know as an actor the star has been
romantically linked to Jessica Bill and
Jenny slate just you know I think it's
very wise to recognize that you might
not know it the new relationship comes
as Chris admits he's ready to settle
down
I mean that's absolutely something I
want you know wife kids building a
family and remember this viral interview
with shondalan maybe Liz you're focused
on finding a
partner in terms of really trying to
find something that you really pour all
of yourself into maybe it's about trying
to find someone that you you're looking
to spend your life with yeah until Alba
the main love in Chris's life has been
his dog Dodger my dog I mean that's the
more love we compile on him the better
the boy even hangs out for his
interviews
now I have to congratulate you on an
incredible summer of movie Magic how
does Dodger handle the bright lights of
Hollywood does he come on set with you
uh he does come to set he's a social
butterfly he loves being on set it's
like his favorite thing because everyone
loves him and you know he knows when
we're in that trailer that any minute
we're gonna go on a big walk and we'll
get to make the rounds and say hello to
every single person probably get a lot
of treats yeah he's a he's a real good
set mascot meanwhile Chris might be in
love but he's still Gotta Wear the crown
sexiest man alive I guess I'm lucky to
be in the discussion in any capacity and
if you ask his co-stars Chris doesn't
mind the new title I had the little um
secret slip of it but uh I think he was
a bit embarrassed but sort of secretly
thrilled you know who wouldn't be
thrilled own it well in my middle school
self thinking
um
you'd rather be part
because this would probably be like the
road to the court
you know
okay but who needs the cool table when
you're enjoying a new Romance
[Music]